brainy major raytrace is a great name
for a topic because radians are four
main things really dealing with and
secondly this is an issue that begins
with measurement namely how to measure
English right in what way
what unit should we use to measure
angles now this might seem like a silly
question to pose like why why do I even
ask this question we already have a
perfectly adequate answer to it and that
is how we measure angles of a while you
distinguish these degrees and degrees
have it serving us faithfully for many
many years in the neighboring 32y
introduced this confusing page some of
you have seen this you're like why why
pies look like it hi Bessie okay because
by not this is right now it turns out
this there are two fundamental reasons
why arlynn mathematics are really very
universe it kind of forces our hand and
says you know what if you want to
measure I've got to deal with angles
then degrees aren't enough to lose
another you need to introduce a new way
of doing this and it's less intuitive to
begin with partly because we've had this
old way of doing things that aren't
afraid to kind of kids begin to think of
those times but once you reconfigure the
benefits are significant okay
so I said that there were two main
reasons okay let me tell you what they
are
the first one is circles the first one
is circuit shut down for me that and
they draw from a couple of small circles
I took waiting now
oh by the way I will show you a super
neat trick to draw circles we pick clips
I'll show you this later you can do that
I'll show you them if you boss it's like
you feel like such a you like such a
badass thing FBI what the page guys
regular but of those of us with this
hand that coordination I'll show you
when we're dealing with circles I think
we all recognize that measuring in
circles is a bit icky it's a little bit
cool let me give an example in fact OPP
- that's why you have to say if you have
some circle right and you say 4 inches
from its radius let's say it's radius is
saying 770 just it suppose on what you
think around some distance around the
circumference right so the kept distance
we call that stuff of a name I could
have distance around the circumference
we call back it up right so for what you
measure some distance around the odd oh
I don't know let's just give me color
say something like this that about okay
so I know how big the circle is right
and look at this arc and I say we'll
look it and the word we use is it's
subtends an angle at the center right
now I don't know I I just made up that
actually what angle does that look like
if you could estimate an angle size and
degrees what you call that one point
what I it's pretty close to 180 isn't it
that's pretty close to like if I put a
straight line
well someone said 120 I think 120 is
much closer than a right angle than it
is to like 150 is halfway right between
that's right
yeah sorry what kgs knob 135 is I think
it's much closer to like 100 because I
need to fit it if I fit in extra 30
degree angle I think I'd get pretty
close to whatever all right now if
that's the art angle there how do I use
that it's all the information I need
how do I use that to measure is love I'm
not actually interested in the distance
I just want to think about the working
of how it looks right what I'm gonna
have to say is look the whole circle we
forward all the way around would be how
many degrees 60 right now I don't have
been tied to university degrees I've
only got a hundred fifty on yes so what
I have to say is look I don't want the
entire circumference I just want that
much of the circumference do you agree
with that like that's the proportion the
little part the fractures circumference
then I'm interested in that we give you
the arm right so there's the part of it
and then of course I need the
circumference right which would be in
this case two PI R which is seven yeah
is that okay so I'm not interested in
the other I just want to look at the
core process the way we get there okay
that's kind of awkward right see what
happens if I'm dealing with an area so
if I draw in anyway if I draw in
something like
so let's say this is a different sample
let's say it has a radius of 5
centimeters like that maybe your hunch
degrees say so if I call that my degrees
by calling the hundreds of degrees again
not interested the actual number how am
I going to work out the area this is the
shape what would I do
this is right triangles unbuttered ooh
me here right thus written fit because I
rule find a side or a table but what a
fight an area to do this thing over
again our time right i what so
proportion of the whole circle not the
whole thing
in fact the proportion that I want is
100 on 360 because 360 would be the
whole thing so 368 364 just give me the
first circle I don't know what the whole
circle I just want this thing what's
this going again starts with an S it's a
sector piece of pie so that's the
proportion of it and then I'm gonna
multiply by just my regular area formula
which is apply swear I'm just going to
pause for a moment really important
concept irregular so that's why your
attentions
okay now hope you noticed right in both
of these cases just simple things just
try to measure a lake or an area right I
hope you see that every time a
conversion kind of has to sneak in
do you notice that right a degrees are
not inherent to the so degree they're
something we introduced why divide it
into 360 equal portions well the short
answer is convenience like 360 divides
evenly into two three four five six
papé deserve an 8 9 10 12 it divides
into a lot of things that's kind of
convenient for us you can go much any
plot out of it okay but apart from that
there's nothing about this circle that
says 360 that is the magic number
okay if anything 360 is the magic number
we've made a magic number and we you
know things like or do a 180 right those
have entered into our language in our
vernacular precisely because we chose
this number but you can see when you're
doing the maths this number is awkward
it's sort of mixed in messy for us you
have to compare so there's the first
reason circles if we want to deal with
circles in a neater way degrees are not
sufficient the second reason is not as
obvious but it is actually much more
important and that is not certain but
Catalans okay this is really why this
topic is positioned where it is in the
sequence even learning things okay
probably just a really rough sine curve
okay you can see here right calculus is
going to take us to things like the sign
X graph
and it's going to be the tool that helps
us understand the gradient okay it's
going to give us the gradient function
now hopefully you can see we know
already just by looking at this thing
but at least the part of it that I've
drawn I have two stationary points
that's nice so I know exactly what the
gradient is going to be equal to and
those two points
however everywhere else along the curve
the great function of this monkey is
completely subject to the number that we
place there right do you agree with that
like the top and the bottom they're
already limited we already know how to
deal with based on the unit circle we
already know that this number has to be
1 and this number see negative 1 that's
that's the biggest and lowest the psycho
can carry that's the range but this
number on the end it's whatever we make
it right so if I make this number a
really huge number like a million okay
then this this graph is actually very
stretched out it's never being the
grated here's quite shallow do you agree
with that if I made it something tiny
let's say 1 that would mean the whole
rap is squash and compress into this
very small space which means it's great
will be very very steep okay
so the grady at this point at this point
and this point all of those gradients
aren't dependent on well what's K are
you going to choose what number makes
sense to put it that makes calculus like
making all the differentiation or the
intervention that we're going to do that
makes it nice and simple and neat that
tends to actually ends up being a
fundamental question this is kind of a
in we're going to spend some time with
circle measurement briefly but this is
really where we're headed
so circles in calculus they're the
reason why we're going to take this
existing unit measurement system and rip
it out and replace it with a whole
who's in a Buick for doodling either
people